die angst begleitet ganz viele menschen
die jetzt dort auch am bahnhof in kiew
sind paul ronzheimer uns von dort
zugeschaltet bei den menschen die es
verzweifelt versuchen die hauptstadt zu
verlassen
der patrizier ich bin hier in der
haupthalle vom bahnhof her wenn du
siehst haben wir wie hier leute
aufbewahrt werden und leute gekommen die
teilweise wirklich hoch sterben hier in
richtung der gleise und dass die
situation wie immer wieder entsteht auf
allen seiten von menschen mit ihren
kindern mit ihren koffern mit ihren
habseligkeiten um noch einen der züge
hier erwischen die hier diese treppe
hochgeht und das staut ist nicht gerade
sehen wie passiv chaotische szenen auch
heute vormittag wieder hier am bahnhof
in kiel und man sieht den menschen an
vielen von ihnen die verzweifelung und
auch die wut und traurigkeit darüber
dass sie jetzt hier die haupt dann
verlassen müssten möglicherweise für
immer das darf man ja nie vergessen
vertriebs ja es geht hier darum ob mit
seinen truppen in dieser stadt kommt
aber diese stadt immer unter russische
kontrolle bringt und dann menschen die
hier sind und die sich als und carina
fühlen vielleicht nie wieder oder auf
langen zeit zurückkehren können in ihre
hauptstadt jetzt wundert es niemanden
dass die menschen dort in solchen massen
wegrennen wirklich aus der kriegs
hauptstadt in kiew aber es war gestern
ja ein bisschen ruhiger als du dort war
erst am bahnhof paul bisschen ruhiger
zumindest heute scheint das ja wieder so
ein massenansturm zu sein wie vor drei
vor vier tagen was hat das
möglicherweise ausgelöst also
möglicherweise auch die meldung von
diesem feuer in dem atomkraftwerk oder
ist es die meldung dass es den 1 jahres
passe in der eu jetzt gibt und dort
zumindest erstmal der aufenthalt
gesichert ist für die nächsten monate
war wie wie erklärst du dir das heute
keiner kann ich nur spekulieren aber
natürlich ist jede meldung angefangen
mit der pressekonferenz gestern und
wladimir putin nur noch mal ganz klar
gesagt hat nein die ukraine ist aus
seiner sicht keine eigenständiges land
und in caroline gehören zu russland er
will weitermachen mit diesem krieg dass
das dazu führt dass natürlich die
menschen sehen putin wird nicht aufhören
damit wenn wir hier mal weitergehen wir
sehen hier am anfang dieser oper wo wir
gerade stehen eine riesenschlange an
menschen da geht man teilweise über die
mauer um hier diese treppe hoch bekommen
wo ich gerade stehe also tatsächlich
chaotische szenen am bahnhof in kiew du
hast es angesprochen das sind natürlich
die nachrichten die es dort gegeben hat
und auch in der nacht das löste etwas
aus bei menschen die sich vielleicht
doch noch an tschernobyl erinnern an
eine reaktorkatastrophe
und auch wenn es jetzt nicht passiert
ist war da ein riesenschock in der nacht
ich bin aufgewacht von den meldungen und
dachte um gottes willen was fast so wird
es vielen menschen hier abgegangen sein
auch wenn es jetzt das muss man sagen
denn warnung erst einmal gibt weil es
ein verwaltungsgebäude ein
trainingsgelände war das getroffen wurde
aber auch solche nachrichten spielen
natürlich mit denn wenn etwas passiert
dann passiert etwas kinder unter ihnen
und dann sind die menschen die kinder
die frauen betroffen die ihr da seht wie
sich allen versuchen dir diese treppe
hoch bekommen denn einige gehen in die
eine richtung anderes in die andere
richtung wir gehen vielleicht noch mal
ein stück runter und euch das noch mal
weiter steigen wie es hier aussieht
das ist die treppe wo die menschen durch
kommen hier und das ist tatsächlich wir
sehen wieder sehr sehr viele kinder wir
sind viele
frauen ihre haustiere mitbringen
[Musik]
wir sehen
ja wir laufen jetzt einfach jemand mit
diesem chaotischen szenen sieht das aus
wenn man in dieser darum geht hier der
kleine hund
völlig verängstigt
müsst ihr antrittsgeld joachim gauck
nein
doch jetzt doch
das ist also ein gegner für sie wenn sie
also
ihr seht es ist hier
wahnsinnig voll und viele menschen ist
nicht ob die am ende ob sie am ende auf
sie am ende ihren zug erwischen werden
wir zeigen ja mal rein das ist der platz
für die menschen hin wollen
nein
das hier ist der hoffnung kann man es
denn das gleiche was in den frieden
führt zumindest jetzt ist dort noch
bieten den vertrieb wird zumindest jetzt
gibt es im lemberg noch bieten für die
menschen aber das sind glücklich
chaotische szenen oder auch tatsächlich
nicht zu vergleichen mit dem was
passiert ist gestern der paul die bilder
die du uns gerade hier nach deutschland
bringt sind die welt bringt die bewegen
uns zutiefst die frage ist natürlich
einerseits eine gute nachricht dass all
die menschen ja offenbar ist noch raus
schaffen aus der stadt aber gleichzeitig
der gedanke im selben moment ja putin
kündigt diese korridore an und die
menschen nehmen das wahr strömen jetzt
aus der stadt und überlassen ja damit
aber auch die stadt den russischen
truppen möglicherweise um sie komplett
zu zerlegen
ja das ist die große sorge die natürlich
viele viele menschen haben kein dass das
bedeutet und das hat er ja bereits in
syrien klickten zeigt
dass irgendwann leid dass er bereit
alles tun wir sehen hier wieder ein
kleines kind mit den eltern unterwegs
eine kleine decke eine kleine decke in
der hand
auf dem weg die heimat verlassen auf dem
weg
bergauf geht das sind massen die wir
hier sehen kann was ist ja tausende und
ich bin ganz sicher nicht alle werden
hier in diesem zug kommen mit ihren cds
beginn
gestellt
da gibt es auch optimistische stimmen
also eine frau die uns ganzen berufen
hat ich gehe nach lemberg aber ich werde
zurückkommen und ich werde in meiner
stadt zurückkommen die frauen viele
frauen und kinder video sind und die
bereit sind ihr land erst einmal oder
ihre stadt erst am meisten verlassen
aber die sagen mir hier hat ja wir sind
bereit wieder zu paul ronzheimer vom
bahnhof dort in kiel vor tausende
menschen versuchen die züge zu bekommen
die züge richtung hoffnung richtung
zukunft weg vom krieg war dass das
gerade angesprochen man vermutet ja dass
all diese menschen kann ich es schaffen
werden rauszukommen hast du irgendein
überblick darüber wie viele züge wie
viele möglichkeiten es überhaupt noch
gibt derzeit die hauptstadt zu verlassen
es gibt sonderzüge die eingesetzten zur
evakuierung und tatsächlich den wir die
gleichen sind ja wohl aber es ist ja
keine panik natürlich haben die menschen
angst in zug nicht zu erreichen aber es
ist nicht so dass man jetzt erlebt dass
es hier schon irgendwie rein geben würde
zwischen den menschen tatsächlich
bewegen sie sich der trend in diese
richtung in richtung der gleise und ja
es werden durch wieder zügig wie möglich
ausgezahlt wie es auch draußen aus dem
bahnsteig einmal wir sehen dort die
massen unten tatsächlich fordert volle
bahnsteige und deren menschen aber der
über die über die gleise dorthin ich
weiß ja wie das am ende war ein suchen
kann weiter hinten ist dipl -ing die
rennen einfach dort hinten über die
gleise ich versuche das einmal zeigen
hier es ist sehr weit weg aber wir sehen
was am horizont wir sehen das am horner
und ja das sind die das ist die
situation hier sozusagen aus der halle
nach draußen gefilmt wie die menschen
dort verzweifelt
von draußen einfach über die gleise
laufen um einen der züge zu erwischen ja
vielleicht von dir in der botschaft in
den momenten in denen du jetzt mitten
dort zwischen diesen tausenden am
bahnhof von kiew stets die sich beeilen
die sagen wir haben doch keine zeit wir
müssen jetzt raus aus der stadt
vielleicht eine botschaft von dir an
alle die wir aus deutschland jetzt
gerade zu schauen wir sehen dass eben
viele tausende jetzt am berliner
hauptbahnhof beispielsweise ankommen und
wir alle stehen vor der frage was können
wir tun und wir werden in den nächsten
tagen vor der frage stehen wie wie
können wir selber ukraine flüchtlinge zu
hause aufnehmen deswegen vielleicht ein
paar worte von dir an uns
ich kann nur sagen liebe zuschauer zeigt
nun realität
zeigt eure unterstützung mit diesen
menschen die ihrer gerade an den bahnhof
laufen sieht von der verzweiflung ihre
stadt verlassen diese wunderschöne
metropole die sie einst hier auf dem weg
viele von ihnen nach deutschland und
wenn ihr ukrainerin viele werden frauen
seien weil die männer nicht ausführten
frauen mit ihren kindern
versucht zu helfen wo ihr könnt wenn es
eine möglichkeit gibt menschen
aufzunehmen dann tut das denn diese
menschen
flüchten aus schließlich vor den bomben
von vladimir putin niemand den ihr hier
auf diesen gleich sehen wollte wir
verlassen die werden gezwungen
und sie sind
die geiseln premier putin und sind wir
zwar jetzt hier ihre heimat standen
palast
wir blicken auf die vollen gleise wir
blicken auf menschen die ihre heimat
verlassen müssen wir uns dass paul
ronzheimer gerade schildert dort am
bahnhof in kiew wo noch ein paar züge
fahren erst mal richtung länder aktiv
stadt im westen der ukraine und von dort
aus geht für viele dann die reise auch
weiter weiter nach polen beispielsweise
viele neuen aber auch wieder
zurückkehren in ihre heimat haben noch
hoffnung paul diese hoffnung für die
nächsten tage ist es schwer
einzuschätzen denn wenn wir eines
gesehen haben in diesem krieg dass
vieles woran man die glauben vermochte
wahrheit werden kann deswegen diese
einschätzung für die nächsten stunden
für die nächsten tage besonders schwer
dennoch du dort in kiew mit all dem was
dort auf sagst mit all den informationen
die du auch gekommen ist beispielsweise
von vitali klitschko dem
bürgermeister von kiew von all dem was
sie die menschen dort erzählen es klappt
wie wird es dort in den nächsten stunden
und tagen weitergehen
man sieht ja keiner weiß wann
werden sein wird was menschen mit
sicherheit sagen und glauben ist
und dass dieser
schlimmstmögliche an diese
schlimmstmögliche taktik diese
brutalität von wladimir putin hier
wieder deine kinder die in richtung
richtung bahnhof warnen dass das
eintreffen wird
davon bin ich fest überzeugt denn all
das was wir gehört haben in seinen reden
all das was wir gehört haben wie er
gesprochen hat all das was wir auf dem
boden sehen und blauen seen all das was
wir den vororten von 14 zeigt er ein ist
genau so wie er es da er
unter ihnen keine existenzberechtigung
und er will sie mit gewalt sich ein
danke bornheimer für den moment dort an
den bahnhof von kiew mitten drin wo
wieder tausende wahrscheinlich sind
10.000 heute rausdrängen aus dieser
millionenstadt 16 hauptstadt
noch einmal drauf da seht ihr die massen
unten auf dem bahnsteig und weiter
hinten wie zufällig von draußen um den
bahnhof erworben menschen über die
gleise steigen um in einem zug nach
lemberg in den weg vom